so coming into uh the opener anthony and
i were having an off-air discussion that
i think we probably need to bring up for
everyone else it's a good
uh i i didn't realize it james my
producer had sent me an article from
forbes i was reading at the break
at the top of the hour and um that that
biden had said
president biden had said in a town hall
uh earlier in the week that he will not
forgive
student loan debt with an executive
order
he doesn't think that that is
constitutional and correct
a little bit shocking very i'm
personally happy to hear that yeah
um but that means it puts it on congress
to pass
and uh and he said he won't support the
fifty thousand dollar forgiveness
only the ten thousand dollar version but
the fifty thousand aoc
and elizabeth warren are asking for it's
a 650
billion dollar price tag now let's keep
that in
let's take this out right so there's 1.7
trillion
yep instantly and that so that will
leave about
a trillion yes if you forgave 650.
we still have a crisis still have a
crisis still have a problem
yep and as i've said many times it is
intellectually dishonest
to forgive student loans while you're
still making them
if they're so bad and people are getting
destroyed by the student loans and we
have to come to your rescue you poor
little people and
washington's gonna be there for you and
we're gonna help you out
yeah if that's the case then you need to
stop making the loans
stop doing that and then also too dave
and this may sound selfish
but i worked my behind off to pay off my
student loans it may not have been a lot
uh but it was still ten thousand dollars
so where's your money where's mine
exactly you know i worked hard and it's
not just me i'm pretty sure we have
millions of people listening right now
like hey i paid off 25 000.
a hundred thousand you know where's my
money so
you know this is interesting we already
know the republican party is not going
they will not forgive
the loans and then there are some
democrats who are like i don't know
neither yeah cause they're gonna have
people like you they're going
uh hello exactly i'm gonna be mad at you
because i want my money back
exactly you know you know and so yeah i
think the um
i don't know if they got the votes to do
it in congress i i don't you know what
this may be a political move on
president biden's part
oh because if he does it he takes all
the heat yeah
if he puts it off on congress and then
they don't do it or they do do it
they get the heat yep and it's not on
him they get the heat from the left if
they don't do it they get the heat
from the everybody that paid off their
loans and want my money back if they do
do it and so
yeah that's basically that maybe
political cover that might be
real good strategy on his part because
if it does go through then he can say he
has something to do with it
yeah but he didn't feel like it was
constitutional to do it with an
executive order right and i'm i i was
shocked though dave when he came back
and said that i'm not going to do 50 000
yeah
i i was shot when i read the article i
said oh oh
okay so right yeah all right so aoc is
not in the white house after all
that's what it comes down to wow very
interesting very very interesting
it's not it's not just political it is
financial it is economic
and there's an issue of uh you know you
have to if you're going to be sincere
yeah and i don't disagree that student
loans are a huge problem yeah yeah
you and i are working diligently to help
people with their student loans yeah and
here's my thing
if they're a huge problem quit making
them and that's my thing before we talk
about forgiving
if that is a conversation let's start
let's talk about how do we stop it
from even happening in the future yeah
once we fix that problem moving forward
then let's come up with a game plan of
how we can help the ones who
we've uh talked and talked them into
doing something stupid but until then
why because we'll be right back at 1.7
trillion
if we forgive this amount within the
next five to ten years well you're going
well and you're going to do it again
exactly because you didn't you didn't
fix the problem exactly you just you
just treated the symptom
yeah i don't know the symptom is a bunch
of people up to their eyeballs and can't
breathe
the problem is making of student loan
debt
and it's out of control it's too high
it's too much
it's gone on too long right and it's
just gotten to be where it's ridiculous
yeah and um but it's very interesting i
you know i know i'm really old at times
when i see things happen in our world
that i never thought i would live to see
dot dot dot happen it sounds like my
grandpa you say
i never thought i'd live to see the day
that was gonna happen i'm that guy now
i'm that guy going i never thought i'd
live to see
the day that they'd actually consider
this crap you know that's what
and they are really considerate i mean
i've said on this show
it'll never happen right it just shows
what i know
nothing i don't know nothing nah dave
but i mean really i never i never
dreamed that the political climate would
get so far left
and so far towards socialism the
government providing all your goodies
that they would actually be
seriously considering doing this and
then it looked like it was a done deal
right and now it's not again right so
it's
very interesting right so the moral of
the story folks is this
anthony and i the ramsey personalities
of the ramsey organization
have committed our lives to helping you
believe and understand
the truth about how life works
which will cause you based on those
beliefs
if you will act on those beliefs it will
lead you towards abundance
yeah if you act on the beliefs that ken
coleman teaches you about careers it's
going to lead you into a better career
if you act on the beliefs that john
dr john deloney shares you with you
about mental health it will lead you to
a more mentally healthy
situation absolutely um which i'm really
enjoying his podcast
oh yeah and if you believe these things
it will cause your actions to occur if
you believe
that the government is going to take
care of you it causes you
to not go cause to take personal
responsibility for your life
which is a key yes for you to become a
to live abundantly absolutely to live in
wealth yeah
and to live a good life you have to take
responsibility for your marriage no
one's going to fix it for you
you have to take responsibility for your
freaking kids
nobody's going to fix them for you yeah
you know god help the people that are in
classrooms today
because some of you are piss-poor
parents and you send
wild animals into these classrooms and
expect these teachers to manage them
i mean it's ridiculous dave's going in
you know i mean because
it but it's not bringing abundance right
it's not it's not and it's
you know and you know
i was with the lady of the day that
works with teachers she she is a friend
of ours that
is a world-class expert in the education
field
and she was saying you know what
helicopter parents are help parents who
helicopter in to fix all their kids
problems
now they've gone beyond that they have
lawnmower parents
i didn't know what a lawnmower parent is
a lawnmower parent cuts the grass out in
front of the child
so they have an easy path oh man that's
different than helicopters
they're cutting the grass ahead of them
so they don't even have to walk on tall
grass
i mean it's just out of control see this
is none of this
personal responsibility is going to lead
you to the greatest dignity
and the greatest abundance in your life
don't wait on anyone else to fix your
life yeah
it's your job that's it dave